amazon has a absolute massive balance
sheet if we look at the numbers amazon
in 2020 their fiscal year ended and the
cash was 42 billion dollars that 42
billion dollars if you combine it with
the short-term investments and total
assets the cash and short-term
investments on amazon's balance sheet is
84 billion
if i was talking to jeff bezos right now
i would say jeff let's sit down listen
real quick you have 84 billion dollars
of cash and short-term investments on
your balance sheet there is over five
percent cpi inflation core inflation is
four percent it is likely that inflation
is only going to get worse you are
sitting on a melting ice cube you are
literally losing billions of dollars of
purchasing power on a daily basis when
you add it all up for the year so if
you're going to lose this year billions
of dollars of purchasing power you have
to do something and the best thing you
can do is to take a depreciating asset
in purchasing power terms of cash and
cash equivalents and to convert some
portion of that into a digital global
store of value if amazon was to take
that 84 billion dollars on their balance
sheet and convert just two percent of it
into bitcoin and leave it there and you
looked over the last 12 months that two
percent allocation of amazon's balance
sheet would have been a protector for
the entire portfolio what do i mean that
two percent has gone up about
400 percent so we would have had an 8
allocation to bitcoin by the end of that
12-month period
that eight percent allocation to bitcoin
would have already been a positive
return on top of the inflation so even
though it went up eight percent in
nominal terms and you took away five and
a half percent we would still have the
entire balance sheet protected even
though bezos would have only allocated
the two percent to bitcoin
it is now time where jeff bezos andy
jassy and the rest of the amazon team
they must put bitcoin on the balance
sheet there is no argument to sit with
84 billion dollars of cash and cash
equivalents on your balance sheet when
there is five plus percent inflation and
those are the official numbers it is
likely that inflation is actually closer
between 8 to 12
based on a number of estimations and so
if you are going to sit there and lose
intentionally and knowingly billions of
dollars of purchasing power that is
unacceptable to shareholders
shareholders should
absolutely start to ask the question why
does amazon have tens of billions of
dollars on the balance sheet but they
have no protection there is no inflation
hedges sitting on amazon's balance sheet
and so as we go into the holiday season
as we are going to see increases in
demand increases in spending more supply
chain bottlenecks it is likely that we
may actually see inflation get worse
before it gets better if that occurs
amazon will become more and more and
more exposed to the negative side
effects of the high levels of inflation
we know that the government increased
their two percent prediction of
inflation in q4 of 2021 back in the
summer they increased it to 4.8 percent
so the government more than doubled
their expectations of inflation already
this year so it is likely that we are
going to see continued persistent high
levels of inflation we've been over five
percent now for four months in cpi terms
jeff bezos and the rest of the amazon
team must put bitcoin on the balance
sheet but they can't just do it because
they think that it's cool they shouldn't
just do it because they think that
people will talk about it on the
internet this is now an economic
argument this is part of their fiduciary
duty of protecting shareholder value
if you put 84 billion dollars at risk
and watch it melt away with historic
devaluation of the currency you're
failing your shareholders
put bitcoin on amazon's balance sheet
that is the only way you are going to
protect yourself the other inflation
hedge assets will not protect you gold
is down 5
over the last 12 months in nominal terms
if you add in inflation gold is down 10
plus percent on a real return basis you
can't buy illiquid assets like venture
capital or real estate you also can't go
and speculate in the stock market the
only thing that you can do to continue
to protect your shareholder value and
also have the liquidity needed is to
follow microstrategy tesla and square
put bitcoin on the balance sheet and
allow bitcoin to protect your entire
balance sheet with only a two percent
allocation jeff bezos it's time put
bitcoin on the balance sheet